I'm Dustin Tardiddy and I'm a Cub Master with Pac-65 in Haddingfield, New Jersey.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scout Master.
People often ask me how many Scouts are in my troop, and it's a little bit more difficult to answer
than you might think, Because on paper we have 36, but when we round them up we get 40..
Round them up, okay, Think about it for a moment. Yes, that's right. Hey, this is podcast number
345..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green. Let's go to the mailbag.
Craig Dixon got in touch and said: listening to your idea about the quarterly program plan,
today, one question occurred to me. You say you basically make patrols based on who's going on
a given quarter's trips, And I should insert here this is something we discussed in the last
podcast. You really have to go back and listen to that before you understand the answer to
this question. But, assuming that you have back to what Craig was asking, what do you do
if Scouts can't or won't go on a quarter's trips? How do you assign them to patrols?
Well, Craig, that's a great question. And first I want to make sure that everybody
understands we haven't really made much in the way of changes to patrols based on attendance.
It's something that we can do, but we found that we didn't really have to do that much.
over the past three quarters since we implemented this whole idea, I think there's
maybe been one or two changes and maybe one kind of total reset. But to tell you the truth,
when they get done- looking at this- the patrol leaders council- they haven't changed the way
patrols are made up significantly. The question that you asked is what if Scouts can't or
won't be going on the trips in that quarter? What do we do as far as their patrol assignment?
Nothing really. They're still in a patrol. It's no big deal whether they're going to make that
quarter's trips or not And so far we've been fortunate that the way the patrols are constituted,
there's a critical mass of them going on the three trips by the time we have that
quarterly permission slip turned in. So not much changes from the Scouts perspective as far as
this is concerned. Last week, in addition to the podcast, I posted an article that I wrote about
junior assistant scout masters and got lots of replies once I put that article on Facebook,
Heard from Earl Bonovich who said: one of my junior assistant scout masters- we have two-
has been assigned to work with True Troop Guides as a team. They're working together to get
our 14 new Scouts acclimated and moving along. It has given the scout in this role an opportunity to
grow and given me the opportunity to continue focusing on working on enhancing our youth leadership
team. Doug Royer said I was a junior assistant scout master in the 70s. It was cool. I could
help wherever needed, Had less predefined responsibility and I really enjoyed it.
Bo Hunt said my junior assistant scout master works with the troop and patrol guys, filled
in for patrol instructor when needed tests and signs off books along with the assistant scout masters,
etc. So if you haven't had a chance to read the article about what is a junior assistant
scout master and some of my recent thinking around that and how I am currently working with
a cadre of junior assistant scout masters in our troop, take a look at that article
And I'd love to hear your thoughts on it. Hey, if you've been listening for a little while,
you have heard a couple of podcasts where I was able to talk with two of my old Scouts,
Bucky and Wade, who are through hiking the Appalachian Trail this year and they're
featured in a YouTube video that you ought to take a look at. I'll have a link to it in the
podcast notes And, yes, I will be checking in again with them soon and we'll try and get
them on the podcast again soon. What are you doing Tuesday morning? If you don't have
anything better to do, come on over to scoutmastercgcom. We start about eight o'clock with a live chat
session where you can just check in and say hello. You can ask questions. We talk about
serious stuff and not so serious stuff. This past week S Vessel, who's the committee chair for
Sea Scouts ship 911 in central Texas, checked in, as did Carl Cook, who is an old buddy,
but I don't think he's been on the chat before. Carl correct me if I'm wrong, And he's a scout
leader with First Portland Scouts in New South Wales, Australia, and is the husband of Best Cook,
who's a girl guide leader, who took the opportunity to check in with us during the chat session
as well. Jim Smith is a troop committee member and an assistant tiger den leader, who also
checked in on the chat for the first time this week. Keep an eye on the Facebook feed and
the Twitter feed. We'll make an announcement when the live chat is up. Go to scoutmastercgcom-
It's Tuesday morning, starting about 8 am Eastern time- And join us. We have great fun.
Before we go any further- yes, that's right- I want to thank all the folks who are scoutmastercgcom
backers. These folks help make the blog and the podcast possible. And since our last podcast,
my special thanks to Dustin Tardidi, John Farrell, Matt Weiss and Steve Byers, who've
all become backers since our last podcast. Thanks so much, folks. There's another way to help out
too, And that's through a service called Patreon, where you can make a monthly kind of subscription
payment. And I want to thank Mitchell Locken, who became a Patreon subscriber since our last
podcast. This is easy to do. If you want to go to scoutmastercgcom, look at the upper right of any
page And in the manual. there you'll find some links that will tell you how to become a backer
or how to become a patron. Well, today I opened the windows because it's nice and warm. It's
spring here. You might hear some birds in the background. I hope it doesn't bother you. It
certainly doesn't bother me. Yes, Then I've got some email questions to answer this week
And I think we ought to get right to them. So let's get started, shall we
E-mail? that is folks. And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Mitchell Locken is the Cubmaster with Pac-20 in Lincoln, Nebraska, where he is also the Cub Scout
Roundtable Commissioner for the Salt Valley District. He got in touch to ask this. I was
wondering if you had any righteous resources regarding roundtables. I'm a new Roundtable
Commissioner and I want to increase attendance. I've been scouring the internet. I found a few
ideas, but I figured I'd set my dial back to the 90s and send you an email. Even though it's not
necessarily your era of expertise, your tenure might be able to set some light on it for me,
even be able to cross-apply something that has worked for you at the unit level
and getting increased attendance. Well, Mitchell, I will give you some advice that I think applies
pretty much across the board. None of it is especially groundbreaking, but there seems to
be two reasonably immutable rules for attracting attention: activity and attendance. Whether it's
a blog and a podcast, like I do, whether it's a troop meeting, a pack meeting, a roundtable meeting,
camping out or any other activity that we do, there just seems to be two things that you
can count on that will attract greater attention and attendance. You ready. One is to offer
consistently excellent content. Number two is to make access to that content as easy as possible
and to make sure that you reward the effort extended to gain access with something of commensurate
value to that effort. These aren't like big hidden secrets. I think they're just very simple
things that we may bypass sometimes in our search for something that we wish would work.
Forgive me for saying so. When we're talking about roundtable meetings, when we're talking
about troop meetings, we're talking about campouts, we're talking about anything like this.
increasing attendance is the wrong goal. It's not what we want to aim at. What we have to aim at
is point number one: indispensable, indisputably excellent content to the meeting, the activity,
the blog posts, the podcast, whatever. Let's talk about something like a roundtable meeting
for a moment. There's nothing indispensable in the information that's being shared,
because people can get that in many different ways. The quality of the presentation might be important,
but it's not quite so important as the less tangible parts of the experience.
There has to be some added value to going to a roundtable or any kind of meeting
like committee meeting, anything that justifies getting in your car and devoting an hour or two
to getting to that meeting and participating in it right, Because there are too many other
ways to get the information that's shared. So the information cannot be the main thing
that attracts people. I think if you look at why boys are in scouts, why they attend meetings,
go on campouts, you'll find some answers. All the other aspects of what they do in scouts
dim in comparison to the central reason that they show up, and that is to hang out with their
friends. It's the people, it's not the activity, it's not the information being exchanged,
it's the relationships that form. that's what's centrally important. So we have to treat scouts
and scouters as more than an audience for some kind of program that we've prepared to present
to them. We have to bend and fit our expectations to what they need and what they want, rather
than the other way around. And the next email brushes up against this subject too.
So before I get into it, I offer this: we can't think in the same way and expect different results.
We have to look at this with a clear head and try and figure out what the underlying
broad principles are that affect these kinds of issues. Let me get to this email.
Barry Dickinson is the Scoutmaster, Troop 175 in Foster City, California, and he said: you
mentioned your quarterly parents meetings and troop courts of honor. I'm assuming you get a
pretty high turnout of scout parents for your courts of honor, but we've been struggling to
get much more than the parents who are already actively involved in the troop, So that would
be the adult volunteers and committee members. We've been trying to give more notice,
sending a nice formal invitation and sending a letter home with the scout when they advance a
rank to encourage the parents to show up. Unfortunately, none of this seems to be
having much impact. We think it's important for scouts to have parents there to see them
recognize formally for their achievements. Should we not worry about it too much?
If we should, do you have any suggestions for getting parents to show up at courts of honor?
Well, Barry, I'll give you the same answers as I gave Mitchell. You have to reward me for
showing up with something that's indisputably excellent. Now you said that you've sent out
notices and you've sent out letters and you're trying to really encourage people to be there
and stuff like that. I'm afraid in my experience, none of that is really going to work. You can't
advertise something like this in that manner and expect people to show up. Everybody's busy
Families are incredibly busy. Every activity their children do ask them to sit in a chair
for two or three hours on a work night with their younger children in tow most of the time,
and the younger children get fidgety and it's some kind of program where I'm sitting down and
you know it's my child, is involved and I really should be there and I understand this,
but at the same time I have a whole lot else going on. So when it comes to what we do, we
try to be the easiest thing going for our families and our parents. We earn their respect and
attention once they understand that we value their time. So we have a quarterly meeting in place of a
scout meeting night on that regular meeting night at the regular meeting time, because
that's already on everybody's calendar, and we make it clear that at least one parent is required
to attend and we- you know that's not an unreasonable ask. If a parent doesn't show up
at that meeting, we're going to follow up, We're going to explain what happened at the meeting and
we're going to remind them that they're expected to attend. You know it's part of the deal
but we're not going to make a federal case over it And we do pretty well, I mean, we get a lot
of people there. We don't get 100%, but we get a very high percentage of our families there
And one of the key reasons why is we keep that evening to one hour maximum, 60 actual minutes.
We aim for less than that. We pat ourselves on the back if we keep it to, you know, 45 minutes,
And I am not kidding 60 minutes. So once we've set that limitation for ourselves,
then we have to do a little bit of work. We have to have a sense of restraint. In
entertainment, it's called, always leave them wanting more. We have to respect our audience.
take a few minutes, write out your ideal meeting agenda or your presentation script.
cut it by 50% and you'll be close to what I'm talking about. So anyway, on these evenings
we start out with a 10 or 15 minute parents meeting. It has to be planned. You can't just
throw it together at the last minute. No, free for all, where any volunteer can just take the
floor, or one of those I'm going to explain: scouting from starting in the year 1910, kinds of deals,
right? No, something that's thought out, that's on a piece of paper, because that's professional.
I know you're a volunteer, but you have to have a level of professionalism and we want to get
important information to the parents. Then we want to answer a couple of questions
and then we want to say something like: well, we thank you for your attention.
We've taken a meaningful amount of your time. We have a court of honor coming up.
We'll be around afterward If you have any questions or you want to talk. if you make
meetings like this so free for all, with 10 volunteers chiming in about this, and that
for no parent plan or purpose, for an hour and a half or two hours, because they seem to like
the sound of their own voices, there's little chance parents will come back. Put yourself
in the audience's seat. Is the information that's being provided to me something that's
vital that I need to know? Is it being provided in a professional manner and respecting the fact
that I am sitting here when there are 10 other things that I could or should be doing? so that
parents meeting- part of it. we usually are done in 10 minutes or less, And then we have our court
of honor, which can be 20 or 30 minutes long. It's meaningful, It's brief. We don't draw
things out needlessly, We don't make it floored and dramatic or overblown. We keep up the pace
and we leave everybody saying that was nice And wow, it didn't take very long either.
So, like I was saying, the entertainment maximum always leave them wanting more. I want to be
done and for people to be looking at their watches and going, wow, that that that didn't take
hardly any time at all, Rather than be in the middle of something and have people looking at
their watches saying, Oh, when is this going to be over? So we have our parents meeting,
We have our brief, meaningful court of honor And then there's cookies and punch for everybody
who wants to hang around, but everyone can leave within 60 minutes of having walked through
the door. Now Barry got back to me. after I answered him. He says: thanks for the feedback.
It helps a lot. Our courts of honor are already on a troop night, but it sounds like they
could definitely be condensed. They're about 90 minutes long right now. So by what
you're telling me, this is shorter than a regular troop meeting. Do I have that right?
Yes, Barry, you do have it right, But people hang around and talk afterwards and we end up
closing the door at the usual time. The idea is that the program part of it- is pretty brief
and then people can leave if they need to leave And Barry goes on to ask: what's the content
or format of your parents meeting? as for the content of the parents session-
I'm the committee chair- reviews what's happening over the next three months and what we need from
parents and the way of money and paperwork and commitments and such, And my part in it as the
scout master was usually simply saying hello and are introducing the senior patrol leader who then
runs the court of honor. You can't inoculate yourself against parents constantly asking questions
about the nature of the program, what happens. So I've kind of given up on explanatory
sessions. I would rather apply the time and effort spent in those to having individual conversations
with parents, and our committee chair handles most of this informally with our families And they
know how to find them. He's there every single Monday night and he spends a great deal of his
time talking directly with parents who have questions about why we're doing something or
how things are working. I'm not saying don't have question and answer sessions in a meeting.
All I'm saying is that men, my experience parents are either disinterested or distracted by a dozen
other things And when they need answers they will ask and my attempts at educating them in a
group have not been very effective. And let's be real: for the past 107 years,
Scouters have consistently complained about how difficult parents can be,
how inattentive they are to the concerns of Scouters, And I don't think anything like
that is going to change. You have to look at this as a feature rather than a flaw.
It's something that we deal with. I did at one time think I would be able to clear this up if
I sat everybody down and explain things really well one time, but I was sorely mistaken.
So keep courts of honor brief and meaningful. Mandate: one parent from each family needs to
be at this meeting. Keep everything as brief and meaningful as possible and follow up with
the absentees. So these past two emails are talking about activity and attention. I want
to reiterate the two key things: indispensable content on a consistent basis and making sure
that you understand and reward the effort it takes to gain access to that content,
So you can exchange program for content if that helps. But I think when we're, when we're
counting heads, we look around and we go: wow, not many people are showing up for this meeting.
Not many scouts will show up for something like that. We have difficulty getting parents to courts
of honor. Let's not look in all the wrong places or think that low attendance or interest is caused
by things beyond our control. I think it's much simpler than that. If you offer people a
consistently excellent experience and you honor the effort that they extend, you will draw
more attention. You will get more participation. If you're not getting attention and participation
well, you're not offering consistently excellent, indisputable, indispensable information or activity.
So I would look carefully at what you're offering, or if you're just making it so difficult to
gain access to what you're offering. And part of that difficulty could be an off-putting attitude
towards the people who actually show up, because what you're looking at. what I mean by that is:
look, you know, I've been to plenty of meetings where you expect a big turnout and hardly anybody
shows up. Okay, And then you get kind of that's, that's upsetting. You've put a lot of effort
into something. Nobody shows up and you and so now you're blaming the people who aren't there,
which is crazy, And that spills over into the people who are there. I can't tell you how
many meetings I've been at that are scouting related, where people sit around for the first 20
minutes and grump about the people who aren't there rather than paying attention to the people who are.
So you want more attendance, you want more activity. check your attitude first.
make sure that you're not kind of poisoning the well and make sure that you're actually
doing scouting. Scouting has unbeatable core content that hasn't changed significantly in
over a century. And when you boil it right down to the basic thing, scouting is hanging out with
your friends, going camping with your friends. When you're a scout age boy or girl, that's what
you're thinking. All the other stuff that's going on, who cares? I get to hang out with my
friends, I get to go camping with my friends. That's what's really important. In that context,
we get to make all kinds of other things happen: skill and leadership and character
development. It's great. If we lose sight of that core thing, we see a decrease in engagement
and activity and attendance And that drives feeling frustrated and angry And that colors
the attitude with which we approach the whole thing, which also affects, you know,
interest and engagement and activity and attendance, And we end up at the bottom of
a spiral where we just decide that it's not worth doing anymore. It's always worth doing.
Pay attention to the people that show up. Make sure that you are aimed at the core
of the matter. Reward whoever shows up with excellent, indispensable content and a great
experience. And remember what that is. It's hanging out with your friends and going camping
for scouts, And it's not too much different from that for any other kind of activity or meeting.
I will say this: a lot of the families who come to these quarterly parents meetings
look forward to doing it because they get to hang out with the other families And they get to do
that because we don't take up all of their available time with things of questionable value.
We try and present high value things. They get to have cookies and punch and hang out with
the other families And, like I said, we close the door usually around the same time on that Monday
night that we do every other Monday night. I'd love to hear your thoughts on this and your
experience with attendance and activity and engagement from parents and scouts,
And I'm going to tell you how to be in touch with me. But before I do that,
I want to put this challenge out to you. Dave Matz is the Scoutmaster, Troop 444.
And he wrote to me asking this question. the new rank requirements talk about conservation related
service And I am curious as to how people are interpreting conservation related service
and what they believe qualifies, as this relates to life rank. Get in touch with your answers to
Dave's question there. I will say this: there's a fascinating conversation you can have with a
scout about this. So what do you think that conservation related service is? What do you know
about it? Who is involved with this in our community? Who would you talk to about it?
I think there's great conversations to be had there, but I'm also interested in your ideas.
Get in touch with me with that. Let me know your thoughts. I'm going to tell you how to do it
in just a moment.
Well, thank you for listening to this 245th edition of the Scoutmaster podcast. Here's how
to keep in touch. Go to scoutmastercgcom, where there's just piles of stuff to access. There's
lots of articles. There's all the past editions of the podcast. You can subscribe to receive
email updates there. We're also out there on social media. There's over 16,000 folks who
like us on Facebook. We have tweeters on Twitter and pinners on Pinterest. You can watch us at
scoutmastercg on YouTube, but if you can't face Facebook and if Twitter makes you better
and you've no interest in Pinterest, you don't put the you in YouTube. Zoom into the late 1990s
and fire off a good old fashioned email. Set the staters to Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E. at scoutmastercgcom. If all else fails, look around your stately manner home
and there you will find a bronze bust of the Bard Shakespeare himself. You will find that the
bust is articulated at the neck. There's a button inside that will open a secret passageway.
once the passageway is open, You'll see a couple of bat poles there. You slide down those bat poles
and I will be waiting for you in the Batcave By now. it should be abundantly clear that the
Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official publications of anyone in particular
other than myself. I am neither endorsed nor sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America or any
other scouting organization for that matter. It is only me talking into a microphone, trying to
lend a hand to my fellow Scouts and have a little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun, here
he is our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir. Until next time, everyone.